how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we actually
have quite a bit of news
we have some captain marvel 2 news which
could coincidentally also be some new
avengers news
as well and then we have some spider-man
3 news about what the new title could
possibly be and i gotta tell you it
makes a lot more sense than the title
that we've recently heard
spider-man home safe so i'm excited that
this new title could actually be
the real title and sounds better than
that and then to top it all off we have
some moon knight and blade possible
details about their upcoming movies and
shows in the marvel cinematic universe
so
let's dive right into it but first if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out
on any of the latest mcu news and so you
can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win
a gambit funko pop all you gotta do is
subscribe like the video and leave a
comment down below to enter
so to kick things off the great news is
that marvel hasn't really stopped
working due to the pandemic yes some of
their production sets have got shut down
but behind the scenes in secure
locations such as directors homes and
such
they have still been working plus they
have definitely been doing zoom meetings
with several people
john krasinski is one of them who had a
zoom meeting with
marvel over this pandemic and further
proof to this is that we just got news
about captain
marvel 2. and that news is that captain
marvel 2
now has a director according to a report
from
deadline filmmaker nia de costa has been
tapped to direct the anticipated sequel
to captain
marvel nia has recently directed the
reboot of
candyman and is now going to step into
the marvel cinematic universe to direct
carol danvers plus a lot of other
characters as well
as you may have heard me mention in the
past captain marvel 2 is reportedly
going to be sort of a mini avengers film
much like captain america civil war
it's kind of going to be an avengers
film just without the title and there's
a lot of new characters rumored to be
introduced in this title as well
and this means that right now currently
marvel studios has
10 directors chosen for 10 of their
upcoming projects we have kate shortland
directing black widow chloe zao
directing the eternals
destin daniel [ __ ] directing shang chi
and the legend of the ten rings
john watts directing spider-man 3 taiko
atiti for thor love and thunder sam
raimi for multiverse of madness
ryan coogler for black panther 2 nida
costa now for captain marvel 2 peyton
reed
for ant-man 3 and of course james gunn
for guardians of the galaxy vol
3. so marvel has been working they've
still been doing a lot even though we're
in this current pandemic which is great
news of course because we're all waiting
for
something a trailer new footage or
simply a show or a movie to come out on
disney plus
but don't worry marvel has been working
and we should get something from them
soon and now for the spider-man
3 news we have a report for a new title
for the spider-man 3 film and the title
like i said in the beginning makes a lot
more sense than spider-man
home safe now this source is not
verified by any means so take it with a
grain of salt but
the recent rumor going around is that
the spider-man 3 title is going to be
called spider-man
can't go home and this is probably the
most
fitting title that we've heard today we
know that spider-man
isn't going to be able to go home at the
end of spider-man far from home
mysterio set him up and made it seem
like he was a murderer
and that's exactly where we're going to
pick up in spider-man 3
spider-man on the run and basically all
of new york city is going to be looking
for him
all of the authorities are going to be
going after him and of course they're
going to go to aunt may's home because
that's where he lives
and they're going to interrogate all of
his friends everybody at a school
so basically his home he's not going to
be able to go back to
so spider-man can't go home is a very
fitting title for spider-man 3. now as
far as when we're going to get the
actual title as i mentioned in a video a
couple of weeks ago tom holland himself
had recently opened up and talked about
his schedule for the next few months
he's going to be filming uncharted and
then he said he's going right into
filming spider-man 3. so in a few months
he's going to start filming spider-man 3
and around that time is when we should
get the title
for the third film and not to mention a
lot of spoilers as well because that's
just what tom holland does
so we can expect an official reveal of
the title coming up here in a few months
and then last but not least we have some
moon knight and
blade news now this news is just a rumor
for now it hasn't been confirmed yet but
it does fall in line with everything
that we've heard so far and the rumor
for moon knight is that it's going to
focus on
mental disorders mental disorders
according to this rumor are going to be
a pretty big part of the moon night
series
now if you've read any of the moon
knight comics you basically know that
moon knight is kind of insane
he does some pretty crazy stuff in the
comics but that's because he suffers
from did
dissociative identity disorder in fact
he has three different personalities
which are all separate from each other
each with their own distinctive traits
and identities so the fact that moon
knight is going to be focusing on
mental health kind of falls right in
line with who moon knight is
and to top this rumor off about moon
knight it is also rumored that marvel
studios would like moon knight
and blade to team up now i've talked a
little bit about how marvel studios
seems to be developing their monster
verse
and reports in the past have said that
marvel studios plans on bringing in the
midnight
suns and this is going to be sort of a
darker more adult
version of the mcu focusing on
characters like
moon knight blade dracula morbius and
the punisher right now as it stands and
appears to be seen marvel studios's plan
is to introduce a lot of different
teams to the marvel cinematic universe
and this is how they're going to
differentiate themselves from
the first four phases that we've had the
infinity saga because as it stands right
now
the future of the marvel cinematic
universe is going to have many different
teams it's going to have of course
the new avengers there's also going to
be a young avengers team
we know that we're getting the
thunderbolts and then we're going to be
getting the midnight suns as well but
let's not forget
about the x-men and the fantastic four
so as you can see there's going to be a
ton
of different groups coming to the marvel
cinematic universe all of which are
going to ultimately lead up to
a secret wars battleworld storyline and
not to mention
these are just the hero teams some of
them are anti-hero teams but
all are going to be used for the most
part to do good we haven't even talked
about the villains yet
with the x-men in the mcu comes magneto
in the mcu and there's a great chance
that he's going to establish his
brotherhood of evil
mutants bringing in some x-men
characters some evil mutants that we've
wanted to see in the mcu for a
very very long time now so as it stands
right now the future of the marvel
cinematic universe has never been
brighter and it's going to be much
bigger than the infinity saga
and there's going to be more than just
one storyline
in the first four phases everything kind
of intertwined with each other that's
the beauty of the marvel cinematic
universe
everything is connected and of course
everything is still going to be
connected in phase 5
6 7 and plus but the stories will be a
little bit
separate from each other with so many
teams it's going to have to be that way
you're going to have the x-men doing one
thing
the avengers doing another thing the
thunderbolts doing one thing and the
midnight sun's doing another
until eventually they all start coming
together and in the final
big showdown the avengers in-game level
event they'll all come together to form
a
massive superhero team which is
something that we're all
dying to see so for the next few phases
this is marvel's plan
establish a ton of different teams and
characters in the mcu
make incredible stories for them both in
the movies and
on disney plus and then eventually have
a villain or
villains so big like doctor doom and
galactus
come into play and threaten the earth
and universe to make
all of these different groups and heroes
come together for a final showdown
with them and this will be the event
that tops avengers end game and this is
what marvel studios plan
is right now so let me know how excited
you are about the next few years of the
marvel cinematic universe and let me
know what you think about the title
spider-man can't go home for spider-man
3. and also let me know your thoughts on
moon knight and
blade let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all things
relating to the marvel cinematic
universe for live updates you can follow
me on twitter and as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof
you